recently like maybe like a couple years
ago yeah and I'm so upset at myself that
it took me this long to watch
a lot of the really shitty hentai dubs
I've watched a few of them I've watched
Bible black and then I've watched that
one where the professor I don't remember
exactly yeah
yeah oh yeah
yeah squeezing on your Supple breasts
nice Janitor's Closet whatever yeah I
don't know what that one's good there's
like a medieval one where like there's a
woman with like f-sized tits It's so
funny and she's like I'm sorry I killed
your granddad by suffocating with my
tits and it's just like she delivers it
straight and the whole dialogue is like
it's so funny
I love it it's an entire like gold mine
of just hand side dance of them they
they turn it into like from a hentai to
a comedy oh yeah it's much better than
the shitty anime
yeah way more entertaining as well in my
opinion I mean yeah because it's
basically just like porn acting right
like it's it's hilarious it's supposed
to be serious but it's hilarious yeah I
guess because it's like they they took
this Japanese script and they're like I
[ __ ] this [ __ ] yeah just make it better
yeah yeah I think a lot of the time the
the licensing deals and those are like
not as strict as the others oh at least
back then they were yeah I guess they
still dab hentai sometimes yeah oh and I
haven't heard like a modern dub hint I
get the casting calls sometimes really
yeah have you taken them no let me take
those yeah I am never the main I am
never the character you're never think
about the guys my voice just doesn't I
I'm not the like the nerdy kid with the
head and I'm not the ugly person you
should do it I'm not doing anything you
should you should do it dude yeah
I can't do this one but that guy who
might be you can play the ugliest basket
no I know you'd like it because the
moment you it comes out you're like I've
been in Civilization
you're a fattest treat anime
that would be on your bio yeah that's
going on the island
hentai because I remember like a lot of
like OG voice actors used to use
pseudonyms uh doing like hentai work so
I remember like uh the Yu-Gi-Oh yummy
Yugi yeah and the guy who did uh
Professor Oak yeah they've both been in
hentai and they have such distinctive
voices it's literally Professor Oak
which one is it I want to watch it
there's there's one about like this it's
this weird like four part uh because I
found it it's just [ __ ] weird it's
about like these um [ __ ] like shamans
and they're like
they're like taking these girls
kidnapping them then [ __ ] them but
then they have like a master roshi type
who's and it's just really weird and
they keep kidnapping these girls it's so
bizarre sentences
it's so weird it's like it's exactly
what you expect of like a weird ass
hentai yeah and what's that one with the
one where she's like oh my tits are
Torpedoes as well
that's like mother's milk or something
that's what it's called they all and I
asked this to the people who made them I
asked them why the English name should
the Japanese ones like the mid-2000s and
ten times were so like pawn-esque yeah
and they were like well apparently just
sold better like when they've renamed it
to like when they gave them shitty porn
title names they sold so much better
than when they gave them literal
translations well yeah because they
probably looked at like a title like
mother's milk and was like I have to
[ __ ] watch this yeah like mother
knows breasts yeah like mother knows
breasts yeah like that was not the
original title like the Japanese titles
are like uh Love Story between mother
and son yeah no no one [ __ ] want to
do this what do you want about I don't
want to watch this but then I think the
weirdest thing I've seen that is just
like you know childhood ruin moment was
it wasn't a hentai but I remember there
was uh there was an AIDS advert right
okay okay where is this going and and in
this Aid campaign right to you know
inform people of our aides yeah
um yeah no no in America okay they hired
the voice actors of Shinji and Oscar
from from Evangelion what and so you
here in this and it is a it's like a
audio campaign right yeah and so there's
a scene in this campaign about two
people having sex and it's like it is it
is just Shinji and Oscar having sex
basically it's just it's just it's just
it's like ASMR oh my gosh it's like I
remember hearing that and I'm like oh my
God I can never look at it I can never
look at Ava the same again oh my God all
we should have I never heard of that
yeah the reporting's on YouTube
do you do a lot of voice acting you did
so for some games right I've done some
I'm not very good I love doing it but
I'm just pretty bad we both did
um what was that game where it was like
a table talk kind of like card yeah uh
card game the dungeon game yeah that
game was like good it's a good game
remember the name of it though
um yeah I mean how good we are put on
the screen later on yeah it was it was a
fun no because Munoz gonna message me
this is what happens we say put it on
the screen and then he messages me
asking what it was and I'm like I don't
know because I would have said it okay
look up Charlie's IMDb it's probably on
there yeah dude I I pulled my heart out
for that I did like four characters as
well I did so much work and I only did
one and like no one played it I was like
no because it was actually a good game I
played it it was fun I did lucious three
though do you know that game oh what is
lucious that's like that's not like uh
you just kill people as like a little
devil child oh yeah yeah yeah I voiced a
character in there it is the worst voice
acting
life have I seen this thing I think I
might have seen this maybe it's it's not
that old it's only like three years what
does the character look like the voice a
nerd he looks very nerdy maybe I've seen
this yeah and this is just like Charlie
voice
in my defense they didn't give me like
direction for the character so I just
read it like I wouldn't like a voice
critical video if they're contacting you
they're probably wanting that voice
right like that but when you see it in
the game it's like it doesn't seem right
yeah it feels like I did a dub of this
character and they put it in I can just
imagine playing the game and you get up
to the no character and be like hey Lose
Yourself
I really appreciate that
it's just like Charlie's boys
[Laughter]
like when you're in something it's like
that's a character when when I'm in
those games it's like why is Charlie
that's what I do if I do the British
thing and people are like I just can't
unhair Connor because when if I ever do
like just my normal voice kind of more
British they're like oh it's
torn yeah
but it's like I'm pompous come here
that's that's what you got to do instead
of learning a new language you got to
like figure out like new accents oh
different accent yeah like if you if you
do if you do like a role in like a
British accent there won't be a they'll
probably hear less of Charlie true I
should have done that if it was me is
that I like I cannot not sound like
myself yeah you two have that you two
have like very very very distinct voices
and it's very hard to hear anything else
when you're changing your voice yeah I
mean I've never heard you change your
voice much I can't do it very well you
can only do Scooby-Doo saying one line
go on to it Reggie
whenever he voice acts it just sounds
like him yeah it does it just I go into
like my YouTuber voice you know not
every voice actor needs to sound
different yeah it's a common
misconception you know there are a lot
of voice actors out there who um just
sound like the same character every time
but they're really good at acting and
really good at making oh you know like
sugimoto like you know it's like one of
the biggest Japanese voice actors he
sounds exactly the same in all of his
roles but people love that things yeah
Johnny Young Bosch always
like the protagonist voice yeah yeah
Steve Bloom just always sounds like
Spike Spiegel yeah that's awesome yeah I
love that he does hell yeah yeah sure
dude oh you know we actually another
thing that we both did
um what was that movie you were in the
last of the grads yeah yeah I was in
wait you were in last time I'm the voice
of the Killer
holy [ __ ] I had no idea that was your
voice that's awesome yeah and if you did
an American accent yeah it's an American
accent yeah they were like he's so I got
on the call with them because I think I
don't know how it all came about
um they asked me to do it and I was like
yeah sure because they were like a
chocolate Center I was like Charlie's in
all right sure because you had like an
actual role in it it was officer Greg so
I was like oh [ __ ] sure why not how
how many lines can it be I was like sure
whatever and they were like so we did be
the voice of the Killer and I was like
all right cook so I get on the call then
we're about to do it
and I'm like I stopped doing the lines
and they're like oh no no no he's
American and I was like oh I wish you
told me that like before because I could
like prep a little bit and I was like so
whereabouts in America is he from
thinking like I'm just stalling so I'm
like [ __ ] I need to think of like a
voice now and he's like ah from
Washington I'm like oh yeah yeah easy
yeah okay yeah I got that so I just
don't do this thing and they're like
yeah it works it was just some kind of
creepy voice I don't know yeah I I but I
think um I I think I don't know if they
fixed it or not I think they like forgot
to credit me in the movie really they
never I don't think in the official
credits of the IMDb I'm credited at all
damn but then again I saw the review
scores and I'm like maybe yeah I officer
Greg really put his best on the line I
saw another reviews like this movie's
shocked but I like seeing Charlie
it was a shame because when I spoke to
the guys they were really passionate
about yeah they really went forward they
really put that on that and it was a
shame because you're like damn is this
one of those things where like you have
a vision but it's just not quite
realized yeah except for officer Greg
sometimes you just get it right did you
watch the whole movie yeah oh okay I
mean I haven't I don't know how I sound
in it I I didn't know it was you so you
sounded pretty good all right okay good
yeah because there was a there was an
actor who was actually playing the
character right but then but it wasn't
their voice he was wearing a mask so you
basically did like the Darth Vader so
yeah I was like it was kind of yeah yeah
exactly right it's kind of like that so
then I think he was unmatched at one
point yeah but I again I didn't have
much time I I when he got like burned
alive and I remember I ruined my throat
like having to do those lines right
because I did it like eight takes and
they were like can we have like one more
and I was like I only have one more this
isn't the tape we don't have anymore
oh God it's so bad oh dude I don't know
I don't know if it's good maybe I should
watch it maybe I shouldn't I don't know
do you like watching like shows or like
movies that you voice in there's times
okay I there's certain voices in certain
voice types and certain character types
that I know that I can just like that my
voice learns really well to and that I I
tend to like if it's a cocky [ __ ] I'm
like okay I feel like I can do that
really well
those type of characters I feel like
really comfortable doing but when it's
more like stuff out of my range I don't
really like watching it because I'm like
man I feel like I just didn't do a good
job all right like you could do better
kind of like I feel like I know I can do
better and I probably should watch it
back so I could learn right um but also
also if it's something that I'm like
it's a it's a video game or an anime or
a TV show that I'm really passionate
about I'll I'll watch it
um uh like I hope yeah I think I think
it's out by by the time this comes out
like Omega Strikers I'm really [ __ ]
excited to hear what I sound like in
that game yeah I don't know what it's
like I'm so [ __ ] hyped because the
game looks good I haven't even played it
because people have to play it yeah
because you've been on tour this whole
time I haven't been able to play it but
all my friends at players say it's so
fun and it's addictive and I'm like no
finally a game that I've watched it
that's good or like they're done good
but popular sorry yeah yeah yeah so
excited for that yeah damn yeah that's
sorry tangent about me sorry about you
it's yours it was us last the grads
is crazy so that's like one two or three
things now we've both like done things
for all right nice
time you're going to be in a movie
together yeah like live action where do
I watch last of grads but I can get it I
don't know if it's still on the same
site that it launched on I think it went
to uh triller
is it shutter or triller yeah the only
thing I know about that is that they
sued the H3 yeah I don't know if it's
truly which one's the horror one is it
shutters the Box
shutter yeah I know the one you're
talking about yeah okay my wife watches
a new horror movie every day and it's
always on this side it's what everyone
she's watching yeah yeah yeah that's the
one with all the horror movies on yeah
that process really really really really
made me feel bad to people who make
movies that don't do well oh my God yeah
it's gotta be miserable I was like
because you know like these these when
we talked to them about it they would
I'm sure you had the same thing like
they were really passionate you know on
you know the I'm sure they all are yeah
it's like it's like [ __ ] could you
imagine putting so much time and effort
in something that people are like it's
jokes and [ __ ] oh funny funny mush man
exam director be like yeah
no that's way more passionate there was
no [ __ ] passion [ __ ] off
this thing had passionate it just wasn't
there I gotta try to finish Exxon now
now
I'm not gonna do that I'm gonna try man
I'm gonna try you said you're on episode
two I got to like episode two or three
yeah three is so [ __ ] bad oh my God
it's probably because they didn't they
never thought anyone was going to get to
three yeah
so that's like five minutes of episode
one I was ready to shut it off yeah it's
miserable they're just like they're so
lazy you just hit like other [ __ ]
stuff playing in the background when
they were recording the audio like
[ __ ] recognition
oh my God